i'm surprised by the methods when
they're not serious
we do not communicate from one leader to
another on these issues by tweets and
letters that we make public
we are not whistleblowers
well earlier this morning the british
transport secretary said that action is
required from the french side to curb
channel crossings
the issue is originating uh
from france it's originating much
earlier in france of course for the
migrants who've made a very dangerous
journey across europe but they're
leaving to come to the uk
from france and it does mean that the
action is required there on the beaches
and that's why we're appealing uh to the
french to work closely even closer with
us uh on this it's in all our interests
to get on top of it
and rob pal still here rob i mean
president macron making it clear he
doesn't like the idea of negotiating by
twitter he wants to do these things
through normal official channels but is
there any content in what boris johnson
said in the letter we've now seen that
has upset the french so i think reading
that letter from last night it wasn't
particularly combative especially
compared to some of the more kind of
overtly hostile briefings and interviews
public statements that we've had really
from the uk side and the french side um
stretching back months over a variety of
different topics be it fishing or albeit
brexit um or be it indeed these channel
crossings i think what has irked the
french is the fact that this letter as
you can see there
was tweeted out by boris johnson um and
i think what we heard from president
macron there was his thought that this
was essentially uh the prime minister
may be trying to add pressure on um to
the french government to do something um
about this i mean he does say doesn't it
that um
i think he thinks the french should take
back people who come to this country
from france and sort of implies that
it's a french problem rather than the
british one i think that was clear from
what grant shaps were saying there as
well it very much does suggest that the
route um the the way to solve this issue
is on the french side and two of the
main suggestions boris johnson has are
already things that the french
government
has essentially said no to in terms of
putting british border force officers on
the french coast to patrol with um
french officers that's already been
rejected
by the french and also this idea of a
returns
agreement whereby uh people that have
made it to the uk coast can be sent back
to france you can see why with an
election looming that would be
politically unpalatable for president
macron so
the interesting thing is when this
letter was written it was designed as
quite a conciliatory letter and i think
they were hoping that this would prompt
a constructive dialogue ahead of that
meeting with the home secretary and
other european leaders you might say
another blunder by number 10 then but it
is a diplomatic misstep and i think
tweeting it out like that um has rolled
the french conservative mps this morning
um though are blasting the french
response tim um tim laughton the member
of the house home affair select
committee um has said that the french
need to get real that this is lives at
stake uh and essentially accusing the
french of overreacting we haven't had
any official response from the home
office
all from downing street uh yet although
we have seen boris johnson i think in
the last uh 10 15 minutes or so he's
greeting the polish prime minister in
downing street at the moment you suspect
they'll be wanting to calibrate their
response uh there is boris johnson there
meeting the polish pm um we'll be
wanting to calibrate their response to
try not to inflame the situation too
much because ultimately if talks break
down and no one can come to an agreement
over this and this gets sucked into a
big political spat across the channel
then the people that suffer ultimately
are the people that are perishing um in
the channel now labor this morning
uh was saying that they didn't quite
know who was to blame uh but we're also
putting the boot into boris johnson this
is the shadow home secretary
i'm not close enough to the talks
between the prime minister and the
french president to know precisely who's
being reasonable who's being
unreasonable but i think we can safely
say that sending that public letter has
that judgment from the prime minister
that that would help in getting this
deal clearly uh has proved to be in
error but this isn't the first time that
the government has failed
and um
interestingly of course the point to
bear in mind is actually
putting to see from the shaw however
dangerous is not actually illegal
and i think when you speak to people in
government as well they acknowledge that
it's very very hard actually for
for french officials for french officers
to stop all migrant boats
um going into the sea just because of
the nature of the french coastline how
long it is there are lots of hills and
dunes that can be um that they can hide
boats in so i think that there is an
appreciation on both sides that there
needs to be something else to break up
this trade and something to
disincentivize people coming across but
i think the problem is no one's quite
sure yet what that is or what's
practical